[Music]
the world
in which each of us and all of us now
live
is full of pressing problems and future
risks
but it is also full of hope aspiration
and opportunity
public leaders can come in many
different guises they can be ordinary
citizens who take up a local cause
they can manage a non-profit
organization or a voluntary association
that provides services to those in need
and security to those who are oppressed
they can be individuals who run for
elective office
hoping to create more economic social or
political equality
they can serve in government hoping to
increase the responsiveness
efficiency effectiveness and fairness of
government operations
in leadership creating public value you
will learn how to face and meet the
challenge
of diagnosing the reality you confront
and designing a public value proposition
that is both
plausibly value creating and actionable
by you and your particular context
through case studies you will see real
public leaders seeking to challenge the
status quo
you'll be asked to reflect on their
thought and action using the analytic
frameworks and concepts developed and
applied throughout the course
the goal is simple learn how to create
long-term public value by envisioning
and enacting a better more just future
for us all
[Music]